the need for discipline disappears when
you love what you do
now yes i agree with that you know i
mean because where else would you rather
be
yeah i agree and that's where i got to
the point with football i never stayed
after practice and kept footballs
never showed up early to catch footballs
until that third year
and towards the end of my second year
when i finally figured it out went to
that dark time
and that makes you average and i was
different i watched i listened to all
the greats and i wanted to surpass them
[Music]
there's a lot of people out there are
you nervous no
no no no no he's nothing there man
[ __ ] i know you're not nervous hey
listen um
why why you know i'm not nervous hold on
okay
okay okay let me bring this in let me
pray
hey everybody welcome to another episode
of hotbox and i'm evan britton
and i'm mike tyson mike we got the hall
of fame
tight end in the house we have greatness
in the house tony gonzalez welcome my
brother
thank you good to be here man absolutely
dude
man so what'd you think about the chiefs
winning the super bowl
uh i was happy as [ __ ] i mean i was
there
obviously we worked it for fox uh and i
was on the sideline
uh i didn't move the whole time because
remember it's been 50 years
since they wanted we couldn't i played
there 12 years we couldn't get it done
uh but and so when when i i was there
and they won
and the confetti was dropped um i had
this feeling of like
so happy obviously i it wasn't me and i
i know i didn't win the super bowl but
it's like watching one of your kids win
i guess you're still making compare like
you're really happy
for them yeah even though i didn't win
it but part of me wanted so i guess
i'll take 75 percent feeling like
definitely
well you know that young kid the
quarterback he um he has the light
yeah yeah so we're gonna watch them when
people have to like we're gonna watch
them now
we're gonna watch all their success all
their happiness we're gonna watch their
failures
yeah we're going to watch their faults
we're going to watch their mistakes
human mistakes that the everyone makes
but he's making them
on the world stage that's the pressure
of him right now right i mean yeah he's
about to become an icon no i'm talking
about life i'm [ __ ] football
that's what i mean i agree with you
she's saying that that icon that's
coming for him now that fame
on a on really an international level
maybe like with
and i look at football tom brady peyton
manning hey hold tight
[ __ ] what makes you why do you want to
be who you are
uh-huh while we're getting right into it
what makes me want to be who i am you
know i think
over the last and i've been a learner
for a long time
uh i went through a it was my dark time
so my second year in the league and i've
told people real quick i
led the league and dropped passes got
benched twice i was on my way to being a
bus and i was i mean
it was it was it got pretty low for me
it's the lowest i've ever had i mean
up until then i was hey i was all
american i was this and that
two sport athletes two sport athlete and
then i went through a depression
uh where i was locking myself in the
room just drinking uh
feeling sorry for myself remember crying
because i'd never been to this stuff but
and then from there it gave me that
thirst for to learn
to really dive in okay what the what is
this thing
called greatness and and how the hell
can i be like
like mike tyson or or or jerry rice or
anybody
like why why the hell did they make it
and i'm struggling right now it ain't
because i'm not big enough fast enough
strong enough i got that
but the [ __ ] wasn't connecting in my
head and in my heart
and so i went on this and i've been i'm
still on that journey that
where i started crushing books on
michael jordan
tiger woods and and started studying
people's workout routine and
i realized that that there's so much
more and then i didn't have that
confidence i lost that [ __ ] i lost that
belief in myself and then i started
getting into books like deepak chopra
seven spiritual laws of success dr wayne
dyer
started going on this spiritual journey
uh that i've been on still
and then over this last couple years
i've really dove into it
and kind of said you asked me who am i
or
at this point it's it's more than just
this body or
the the the success i've had it's it's
like that
shedding of the ego like going behind
that
and saying okay i'm this i'm i'm love
i'm peace i'm joy i'm really whatever
the [ __ ] i want to be honestly
at this point like you have that power
uh
and and i've been able to sit down with
some really great thinkers
and see that you create
you create who you are i mean you you
are what you think
uh and you need to quiet your mind as
often as possible and there's a lot of
ways to do that we can go
into that but there's there's a lot of
ways to quiet that mind to get down to
who you are
behind this body this this meat sack
that we are yeah it's deeper than that
you exist
i think i'm here for the human
experience and after this where i came
from before
i feel like i'm going to return there
and
and that's that's why we're here to have
this human experience and to go through
life
and to see to have to fail to love
to have peace to have joy and you have
to keep leveling up you have to keep
learning those lessons
otherwise life will keep hitting you
over the head
you become who you are what makes you
what did you see that say hey i want to
be this
i think that i was i was curious who's
your father
with my biological father yeah uh
joe gonzalez from new york uh
son son son of immigrants he's puerto
rican no he's uh my grandmother's from
jamaica
yeah born in jamaica and uh
and my grandfather was i guess raised in
argentina
and then they met and had my father in
new york and so
my dad was a is as uh
he's a psych therapist was a
recreational
recreational therapist not a doctor no
we
we're not too academic on that side of
the family but he was a recreational
therapist at the long beach uh
in long beach at the veterans hospital
for 40 years
um yeah oh what was it that what was the
thing how did you
take that how did you take that first
step
out of the darkness uh
the first steps was i needed to
i needed to fall in love with what i was
doing i loved that dude and and i think
i played basketball too i don't know if
you knew that but i know we didn't
yes so and i was i was i was pretty good
at i mean i played at division one level
college went to sweet 16 and so i'd
always loved
that was my first love that cow that was
my first love was basketball
secret and football was just something i
was really good at
but football is tough man it's just it's
not boxing
but you're getting your ass kicked no no
you're getting your ass kicked
football's the ultimate man sport yeah
yes
ultimate man i'm a fighter and i know i
know football but i know what that
listen i can go in the boxing match and
knock a guy out in 10 seconds
30 seconds you got to play that game
yeah
you got to play that duration i don't
care that's what i found out
about um lawrence taylor i don't care
how big you're how strong you are you're
going to get hurt
oh yeah and yeah yeah i can be lucky and
have a 30 minute 30 second fight
most of my fights with her
and he got i don't care how big a tuffy
he has to go through that duration
he has to go and never got that the
whole objective is to hurt him
imagine that yeah i can do that for that
one but imagine you're having seven
eight guys 10 guys 20 guys their
objective is to put you out of business
80 times a game yeah 80 times and i was
to put you out of business and i was i
didn't i didn't have that
streak in me yeah that that ability to
go to that level
that that you got to go to at football
that yeah
and now and this is where it gets
dependent i've had these conversations
in the locker room
like uh it's a it's a violent sport
and you have to go there you got to take
your mind to that
you have to be a different person when
you step on that field and i had a hard
time with that
and uh and uh and basketball was just
fun
basketball's just fun you can go play by
yourself football you know no one wants
to say hey let's go get a couple
hitting drills at least my mind didn't
like that i was like screw
that that's why i sucked when i first
played uh i used
i quit pop warner my first year i didn't
even i didn't like hitting people i
liked playing football
on the on the playground when it was
two-handed touch yeah you put some pads
on i got to run into you full speed with
my head i didn't like that
uh and so anyways that's what happened
to i fell in love with the sport
and and when you're in love with what
you do
um to me discipline
people throw that word around and just
the way i view it is discipline there is
no need for
you the need for discipline disappears
when you love what you do
no yes i agree with that you know
because where else would you rather be
yeah i agree and that's where i got to
the point with football i never stayed
after practice to catch footballs
never showed up early to catch footballs
but
basketball i did all that that's i used
to go to the gym for five hours a day
but in when football then i did that i
never did that the first two years
until that third year and towards the
end of my second year when i finally
figured it out went to that dark time
i was like [ __ ] jerry rice is you study
his workout routine i don't know
and i'm not doing that i just show up
and do what's required of me
wow that's interesting and that makes
you average and i was different i
watched i listened to all the greats and
i wanted to surpass them
one guy would run five miles then he
walked back five months after he
finished running then walked down the
car
and whatever they did i tried to
supersede that
and by doing that by super seeing all
the greats i destroyed my body
and then i found out um training hard is
ridiculous
to train smart yeah you have to change
smart like what do you say you have to
try
smart because you're you're told so many
times the greatest did this the greatest
did this
and at the end of the day when it's all
over look how the greatest look yeah
yeah yeah no look at the greatest look
yes and so you have to find that balance
yeah listen but know what's up
interesting about the greats even though
we see them [ __ ] up
we try to reach that level but we can't
only the graves could reach that level
[Music]
only integrates it's interesting though
when you study greatness
and you study whether they're a business
leader
or an actor yeah like the endurance
factor of
the greats yeah the endurance like damn
words
how do you work that long and hard and
then get up and go do it again the next
day yeah and these guys are doing it
uh i had a chance to hang out with with
um
dennis rodman a lot when i was younger
d-rod he's a friend of ours oh guys
i love love dennis and we used to go out
and he was the first person who taught
me this is right after i had some
success
and uh we'd go to vegas or whatever and
we'd get home late we'd party all night
and but he would call me at we get home
around five or whatever
5 30 and he would call me at 9
30 in back hey hey bro let's go
come back what do you mean let's go like
we're good i can't i can't move right
now
and he's like let's go work out let's go
come on and i'd like the endurance
like this is why yeah like how do you
can you force yourself to do that no
this is what um
this is um when i watch somebody like
aaliyah what's somebody
that's really the real deal you know and
i say well
did i know i'm not great
no no no no when you see greatness then
you know that's not me
are you what do you mean that's just my
ego no that's just my ego [ __ ]
ali aliyah fight you til he die you have
to kill him
he's not gonna quit yeah
not really i um
i want to believe that i'm that guy my
ego tells me that but
the reality of it is that i love my
beautiful wife
i love this life that i have i can do
almost anything
and i might i might not want to
give this up just to prove that i'm a
tough guy
but i'll leave wood yeah well there
might have been a time in your life
though mike where you would have given
it all up
well i believe that was i said um i just
know i'm not him
[Music]
that's what i know everybody could call
me what they want in this and that i'm
not greater than my because i am
but i know i know what greatness is
i know real quickness is um
ali's an interesting guy you know he's
um he's really beautiful he's better
looking than you
and his right and um
he's really mean and tough and
determined and
competitive and well let me call it
another he's really game
what makes him what why is he that way
why that's what i'm that's what i'm
after too like what makes
somebody what what is it it goes beyond
himself
understanding yeah yeah
i think goes to the level where i'm
afraid to go yeah
and i've seen him like randy moss jerry
rice yeah workouts like people like
you're throwing up every day people
can't handle it
yeah michael jordan type stuff talk
about endurance
the legendary stories about him yeah uh
kobe bryant
late kobe bryant him you know getting
five
three thousand makes that takes five
hours yeah three thousand makes
yeah in one practice and then come back
and do it again the next day like
what's it about somebody that makes them
want to do that
what do you think a lot of that a lot
believe it or not a lot of it has to do
with self-hate
you know they want to be something they
saw something and they want to be that
and they feel they're not that
and if they're not that they're not life
is nothing life's never
i believed if i was an heavyweight
champion and stuff like
my life was nothing
it's a thought it's like this um where
did we get i thought who created the
thought
how did we um you know i know i heard
that story of [ __ ] um
the guy that saw himself in the mirror a
greek guy that fell in love narcissists
and stuff but
it's deeper than that it's better than
nothing because most of us
um most of us don't like ourselves
and we succeed and do so much greatness
and we're jealous of ourselves
can you imagine that i think it's the
energy that we're jealous of
you know because sometimes i say to
myself i say
why am i listen why am i on this show
you know what i mean
i say to myself [ __ ] i'm not that
[ __ ] smart i get all this [ __ ]
mics or google mike's this and that mike
has to deal with some
he has to deal with uh a lot of um he's
a megalomania but they have a low
self-esteem
isn't that great i think i'm caught but
i i'm deep down inside i feel like i'm
[ __ ]
but without that i can't um i can't be
who i am
does that make sense to you it does make
sense and i think i've felt like that at
times
and i and i really this has really just
happened to me over the last
year that's why you're in half we become
who we are
because we don't like ourselves but
here's here's what here's what i want to
get to this point that
i heard a great quote that comparison is
the thief of joy
and yeah i realized that i was always
trying to compare myself
to that guy he's got more money than me
or he's more popular or he has more
stats he's more yard oh he blocks better
than me
or whatever it is i i don't have a ring
i never want oh [ __ ] i've never won a
super
like it's like stop comparing yourself
at least this is what i tell myself and
i do this every day through my morning
meditation
it's a lot of like just let all that
[ __ ] go let it go
and just be your best version yeah
and don't put all that pressure on
yourself because i think that's where
you start to judge yourself
yeah that's not being in your heart
totally man you know and i wanted to
and coaches always said play with your
heart and i never understood what that
meant
but to me what it means now is when
you're in your heart there's no fear of
judgment
you're totally present you're not
worried about the past what happened
before you're not worried about the
future that's why a lot of guys
miss the ring the ring maybe or why guys
would miss the the field because
where else can you be that present but
you can you can
you got to work at it and then it
becomes habit just like became habit to
be on the football field
you can become habit in life where you
can just be totally present you just
keep to have to keep con
concentrating constantly reminding
yourself that
there's no outside rather b that i'm in
love with like until you're in love with
life now
exactly and before when you're comparing
yourself it's hard to be in love with
life listen
and i'm mad that i love life i don't get
mad [ __ ] [ __ ] what the [ __ ] you so
happy for
but it's just let that go mike you know
it's just beautiful [ __ ] that's that
street [ __ ] that holds on to you that
privilege
why are you so happy for a [ __ ]
you know where you came from but i
should be happy because look where i
came from and look where i'm at now
yeah but it holds you it's almost like
your mother gave birth to you
and you when you're fighting it no
you're looking for your independence
[Music]
i love it it's good [ __ ] man you guys go
deep on him yeah we go deep bro
i love it well what was your last year
17
16 what do you mean your last season uh
13 13 you're thirteen two thousand
seventeen you've been out
you've been out a little while now going
on six years now okay
so um how has that been it was tough
to be yeah yeah transition's tough yeah
i'm five years out now my last year is
14 and i feel like i'm just getting back
on my feet just getting back yeah
yeah it takes at least at least for me
yeah it took around three years
and stuff because um when we're doing
our sports or whatever our career
this is why we're not we don't have to
focus on us because we have our career
life is about um what's that word again
i want to use the
inventory doing self-inventory yeah
yeah you know i do a lot of
self-inventory and you know what i
notice um
i can't judge myself because i if i if i
if um
i'm always fail my inventory my
inventory is like how did i talk to that
person today
did i just respect somebody did i hurt
somebody feeling today
or did i bring joy to somebody today you
know and
most of the time i failed i've hurt
somebody yeah so i don't i don't i don't
pass my inventories
within the day that well well as long as
you're being honest with yourself no i
have to do that even if i'm not honest
to my
whoever i love and care about right i'm
always honest to myself
and i i deal with that pain but being
honest with myself i deal with pain
yeah i deal with pain with just um being
disciplined
yeah you know with life i have to be
disciplined not in sports but in life i
have to be yeah
i learned discipline is doing what you
hate to do but do it like you love it
yeah you know and
that's where discipline comes in handy
you got to have discipline
uh but when it comes to what you love to
me there's
i think discipline the spirit goes back
to that like if cookie i love
sweets and [ __ ] i can't help it i love
them the cookies
and if i gotta have if i see two cookies
in front of me and the chocolate chip
and somebody tells me i i'm gonna eat
the whole plate i'm like hey you gotta
get this out of here and it takes a lot
of discipline
i don't know what i love huh how about
if i tell you i don't know what i love i
do it because i believe this is the
right thing to do uh
i believe because he told me this this
is why i did it mm-hmm
you know yeah
oh you do it because you love it you're
saying is that what you're saying
no like you don't know why you love it
well listen um
how do you know you love it um the
cookies
the sweets my temperature rises
yeah yeah check it out it's 1970 what is
it
1978 79 something that affect i'm in a
reformatory
with bad kids i've robbed some people so
we're all locked up here
muhammad ali came in there he came to
visit the kids
i saw him and um
my life started stressing hey i bet you
nobody picks on them
it's my mind was saying this [ __ ] i just
by the way people when he came in people
would have
lost their mind the people that abused
us their staff they lost their mind they
were crying
the people that were abusive they were
crying when they saw this man they were
at his mercy
yeah so i said i bet you nobody picks on
him
and then um a couple of months later i
got shipped out to another prison
another child prison
and then um and then there i met a guy
that used to be a [ __ ] fighter
professional fighter he started teaching
me
how to fight he kicked the [ __ ] out of
me at first but he started teaching me
now after he kicked my ass just to let
me know
i'm the boss you know he was a smaller
guy to me
and um it's to let me know but um he
taught me then he started teaching me
and then i'm bobby stewart then i i'm
almost there in my job i
broke his nose he had the black guy and
he was mad once i thought he was mad
but he was mad because his wife don't
didn't like him having the broken nose
and stuff
he said listen i'm not gonna be able to
box with you no more but i'm gonna take
it to this other guy that's gonna take
it to the
to the next level and then i met custom
auto
how does that happen i see [ __ ] my
how am i leaving i start boxing
and then food then sugar wait let
leonard fought roberta's iran
after seeing that fight and seeing how
people respond in the crowd
and how the fight just has so much
control with life
everybody was talking about that
commercial with duran and linda
everybody was 1980 so the fight june
20th 1980 they fought in um
montreal canada i watched the fight i
got turned out about fighting i said
this is what i'm gonna die doing
[Music]
and and i met cousin this [ __ ] right
isn't that
people that's what life is about beating
people people
inspiring people just even me a guy like
me i have a little self-esteem i inspire
people
to be like tyson fury to be people named
nice heavyweight chair
i inspire people even though with my low
self-esteem
i just inspire greatness and they're
crazy yeah
because it's bigger than me it has
nothing to do with me man how i feel
about myself is nothing how i feel about
life is nothing it's just
how's the energy how you feel about
yourself as part of your journey though
absolutely but my illusion of myself is
like [ __ ]
listen i'm talking about my illusion of
myself
listen um i don't know what's wrong with
me i was at the table with cousin my
friend
he was a fighter too and he said
something about alexander the great and
why did i [ __ ]
he said he said he was like six five
during like
300 years before christ he was like six
five but he wasn't he was really little
and little
he really small he was so small that the
[ __ ] um
the equipment couldn't fit him he was
too small
you know but his solution of himself was
big yeah
is alexander great too yeah yeah there's
also something
that i heard about him too that his
mother
told him from the beginning since he was
called that he's yeah you are destined
you are part of the guy
his mother is one of the first stage
mothers in history
but they've been before living thousands
of years millions of years before
they've been stage mothers that inspired
their son
alexander when you talk about alexander
degree you talk about him and napoleon
and noah's um
the resemblance between the two because
they were
the day we call them bitch-ass [ __ ]
you know because they're wins not
because they might be gay but just
because they're wimps and stuff and
that's what they were they were afraid
of their mothers
can you imagine that those powerful men
are afraid of their mothers
that's why i was down to the great now
he always kept most men though
most men are afraid of their mothers
well especially when there's no father
there
yes we are they beat us viciously
and they love us but they believe that's
how men are supposed to be treated
yeah ain't that crazy interesting they
believe that's how men are supposed to
be treated but then you see my but
you know but then you see my wife after
this she's babies
i see her [ __ ] how you see how the
women of her family treat the men
i watched her family i watched the aunts
and her mother ice watch it
and they loved the boys they papered it
pampered the boys
and i come from the house where the boys
get their [ __ ] ass get kicked in the
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here
[ __ ] you want to fight me i'm your
father you want to fight i fee get the
[ __ ] out
i'm from that world i'm from the world
where we
we automatically pixel in the sun make
them harder so we can kick them out
i'm from that world but now being being
around the world let the world change
now i'm a [ __ ] and i want every time i
have a daughter that's um
yeah in that world and um
why am i tough though my boyfriend is a
[ __ ] i'm weak
and then she wants i love her to death
in this stuff no why because she checks
me i can't say [ __ ] i can't say [ __ ] i
can't see who i can't say nothing
derogatory about women or nothing
cause she hey stop that [ __ ] no stop
she's just weird nah
and um she's the only one in my family
that checks me
that's funny how your daughter is
capable of that huh yeah hey i don't say
it stop that don't talk
don't say [ __ ] what do i say then say
small person what small person
hey small person how do i get to harlem
hey small person what time is it
what are you talking about but um
i don't want her to ever run away so i
just say i'm with it i wanted to stay
close to me
i love her to death i just listen to
what she says
you know it's don't say [ __ ] i don't
say [ __ ] i don't say ho i don't say
nothing i'm just
i'm not who i am when i'm around
yeah because something about her
something about her is my mother
interesting the way she's not afraid of
me is my mother
how come all my other kids made one day
i wish they would [ __ ] step to me
why does she why this why is she the one
that i'm i bow down to
isn't that weird [ __ ] huh i'm a [ __ ]
monster i'm boss in my household
and now i'm gonna buy down to her
because i don't want to lose her i love
her so much why do i love this girl
she's [ __ ]
she's in that world she does that thing
she's just so different than what i ever
believe in but i guess
i don't want to have a loser
all of our fears come out in our
children well if i know
forgive me all of our secrets hmm
well i secretly come onto my children
so besides that
what's that what about your children you
have children yeah i got four kids talk
to me about that uh i got an older one
uh when i was younger tell me how old is
he he's 18.
well he like what's his name his name is
nico how do you feel about him
love nico he's about to leave talk about
uh he's a senior
and he's going off to college next year
so uh it's fine
you know what i'm i'm happy to see him
get a chance to go be independent
yeah it's good man to go fall down
because he's
got to you create such a safety net as a
as a parent who has you know yeah i've
done well so i
i'm able to take care of all his needs
but that's the beauty of of letting him
go
as much as i'm gonna miss him i'm
looking forward to seeing him
deal with failure to go through his fear
when we talk about
all the kids i got a 11 year old girl
nine-year-old boy and then we got a
five-year-old daughter that we adopted
wow um and
seeing her all their personalities come
out and how they react to certain things
because i've always been fascinated too
like
like i got my brother my biological
brother
and uh and three adopted brothers
and we all kind of grew up in the same
house the doctor brothers came a little
bit later like when i got to high school
but my biological brother which is it's
different we're wired way differently
and the same you would think the same
lessons
because the same household but he'll
handle things way differently than me
uh and uh it's with your children you
see them
how are they going to act around each
other and how are they going to
how are they internalizing what i say
see there was a great story about um
patrick willis he played linebacker yeah
i remember him one of the greatest
linebackers he retired from san
francisco
awesome and his his parent his childhood
was i think his brother died
yeah he got his one of those those
childhoods like
talk about being from from the ghetto
and not having [ __ ] yeah and basically i
think his mom was a drug addict and i
hate
hopefully the story's not i don't know
if the exact story i just know his
childhood and he got kicked out
basically was like that movie blindside
where yeah
where he grew up with uh a family
adopted him
uh but then this guy's gone on to do
great things he's such a great man
he's incredible you meet him in person
like i love that and this is who we go
against like i go against him a lot yeah
and and he was a heart and then off the
field too with
charities and just a nice guy just a
massive heart
massive heart and then you ask him you
go why what happened
like what happened to you being from
where you are
and he says uh what choice did i have i
had no choice
seeing what i've seen growing up i had
no choice
and you know how many people are in jail
or in bad circumstances that say the
same thing i had no choice
look how i grew up and so it's funny how
he took it that way i have no choice but
to see them and go hell no i don't want
to be like that i got to go this way
where a lot of people will say i had no
choice look at them i might as well be
that way
like what's it about him and his heart
that that clicked for him that way and i
look at my kids and
and i look at me the way i did it and i
love my brothers
but you know we all make mistakes but
it's about how you how you bounce back
from it and how you say well
i'm gonna move on now and go this
direction i'm not gonna keep going that
direction and
so i'm looking forward to see if i can
guide my kids
to dealing with that fear and with that
adversity
and making sure that when when the [ __ ]
hits the fan like it's going to
like it's going to a lot of millennials
don't want to hear that but you're going
to fail and that's part of it
that's part of the process i want to i
want to give them the tools on how to
how to deal with that adversity when it
comes you know um that's so awesome that
you did i wish um
[ __ ] um you know
you're awesome awesome parent but um
when i was because it was all about me
being
in love with myself and i'm better than
everybody else
can you imagine that yeah he was an
older guy he was dying soon so
he didn't have time to explain hey mike
you know maybe you shouldn't do that
to girls or maybe no we need um he
wanted greatness he wanted another
heavyweight champion
and um he was just
that's just who he was he didn't afraid
of death for dying he just wanted the
accomplishments and stuff
you know i come from a world where
people are just ego based
and ego driven i come from that world
where people are yourself
they come from being um brutalized
beaten and stuff and
yes um i don't know i got
[ __ ] i've my influences from
yes old [ __ ] jewish communist
people you know intellects though really
smart intellects and stuff
because i never went to school and you
know i say words and i just learned this
from being around them all the time
you know and um i was interested in life
i can't i was um i was raised you know
you see i got chase affair i see i got
mao on me
and um i was raised by that type of
mentality god has loved castro i thought
castro was a wonderful man
stuff like this it's just my world you
know him and where i learned a lot about
books and stuff
the prince i learned a lot that's all
they talked about they talked about
books they talked about
um who was that guy named the great
writer what was in a toast store they
talked about him and wait we talked
about
these guys they know these people are 80
years old when i'm 14 so they've known
they've known people like toaster's wife
or his nieces you know this is just
people that had
experience with people but you were
fascinated by that when he was telling
you that those stories
you were listening were you listening
absolutely listen um
absolutely and you love that stuff like
why did you love that because like i
said i had
my father and my mom got divorced when i
was six
and i saw my father on saturday very
religious man but
i didn't see him during the week so he
wasn't went around
not a bad guy just just wasn't around um
and took us to trips i want to make sure
because i don't want her he we did
he took us on trips but i had a step dad
named michael saltzman he's passed on
when he came into our lives old uh
not older just a jewish man very jewish
uh lover of books like i said i don't
come from that educated background
like my family we didn't do that that
wasn't us
but with him this man who came into my
life was like all about books
and higher learning and he would tell me
these stories and we always bonded on
books and and lessons of life and we got
into like the whole
i remember the da vinci code oh yeah
the symbolism of of what life is and all
deep conversations but i listened to it
i was into it where my brothers they
could they could honestly they didn't
give a [ __ ]
like that's where him and i bonded and
i'm wondering like like why
why were you so into that like what did
what what about that spoke to you
um noah spoke to me because um i had no
perspective on myself
so i meant nothing to me so i look for
something
to become something do that make sense
you're a seeker
yeah that's what it is right there yeah
that's what i think that is yeah it's
that secret it's that curiosity
yeah you got to be curious if you ever
want to be great
yeah absolutely everybody we talk about
if
if you're going to be great at something
you better be curious yeah
well i think it's pretty quick
greatness is the willingness to die
escalateness like you see these guys um
you know forget about suicide guys
forget about the guy just people you're
some
that are decent people just decide to
kill themselves
you know what makes a person does that
and they do it young age
15 and it's just um how do you say it
this
is 15 20 years um you experience enough
life to realize hey i don't want to be
here no more
it's something about yourself that you
just hate so bad
any kind of killing is a form of
self-hate
you know if i'm killing some issues
everything i say about if i call my
dirty [ __ ] that's because i'm a
dirty [ __ ]
if he's a [ __ ] ass [ __ ] because i'm a
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] we reflect
on one another that's why people inspire
about that's how can we get inspired
you know could be a reflection of one
another
and they allow us to know what we can be
even though we're in bad situation this
is what we
can be my whole life is about wrong
listen i come from that world of rob my
mother's
slept with me my father's a pimp and
this thing says it's my world
can you imagine look at me i'm a [ __ ]
savage
i've see my mother's sleep with men's
[ __ ] men and i it's just it's just
who i
am sexing me um that's probably why i
got in trouble with sex because
sex in me is like whoa it's it's like
breathing
and i know it should be like but it's
just like breathing like perversity and
sex and that stuff and me in the room
and a bunch of women like snacks and
that's just that's a natural to me
because that's who my mother and father
is
you know yeah even to this day right now
i have to check myself
always check myself yeah you know
my wife is my consciousness huh
why is my masculinity in a woman my mom
my cause my wife my mother [ __ ] me up
that's why my masculinity isn't a woman
why am i so overbearing to my wife how
much my wife must say this nigga's
overbearing this look at you love me but
the [ __ ] is too much
i know she must think that you know i'm
kind of afraid of losing her
and i said i think to myself when i'm so
aggressive and i love and i give her so
much love that's chasing the whole way
but why can't i control it why can't i
just stop and being immaculate
with other people why can't i do that
with her the way i do with everyone else
the other women like
they're nothing because my masculinity
is in her because my mother [ __ ] me up
in some kind of way
seeing a [ __ ] minute seeing men [ __ ]
her and how she responded all that stuff
and i want to make people respond the
way my mother responds
when i'm [ __ ] i'm making love
whatever we call it
i'm looking for those sounds that my
mother made i heard her say
does that make sense hell yeah
yeah that makes sense yeah it's like how
do you
how do you unseat something can you
no you can't yeah no no no brother okay
listen i'm in love with those
i'm in love with that picture are people
[ __ ] my mother i'm in love with that
picture that ecstasy
that passion i'm in love with i keep
rolling those pictures in my head i'm in
love with the picture i'm addicted to
that
yeah different
and how do you well at least for me like
i said like
going through hard times and
how do you change the story how do you
say
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna change the
story i'm not can't change what happened
but i'm gonna change the narrative
on how it spoke to me and i'm gonna make
it speak to me this way now
instead of that negative way i'm going
to make it be a positive way
and be a light going forward when you do
that then no that sounds great
sounds yeah that sounds good but then um
and then we're dealing with what you're
dealing with now
um you don't you know you don't want
these people to know that i do this
like me i i have no secrets of anything
everybody i'm so passparent
that's why i've lost so much you know
so this is my only freedom being able to
be on this mic
and i don't like this because um this
makes people think that i'm somebody
special i don't want nobody to think i'm
somebody because i don't
i don't have a good opinion on myself
you know but for my ego this is great
you know my ego is something i'm trying
to
get away from but when i get away from
that ego when i get when i um
distinguish myself i'm such a coward i
need it back because i'm
oh i hate myself when my ego goes away
i'm a [ __ ] i'm like oh i don't know
what i am everything i'm afraid of i
don't know get come back
i don't know how do i how do you how do
you get rid of that guy
you talk about him yeah um
we need him he's he's here for a reason
why is he here
and we keep getting away no my ego tells
me something about you it tells me
something listen i tell you you
you going to do this [ __ ] look this is
where i got you i got you here with rob
i got you here with tyson [ __ ] um
ranch i got this this is what i got for
you mike
but listen only thing i want you to do
to pay me back
all right i just need you to um i need
you to [ __ ] up
and then we're even that's my ego tell
me you need i need you to [ __ ] her
you [ __ ] and then we're even michael
but i don't want to [ __ ] nobody but my
wife
yeah but does somebody say i gave you
all this just do me a favor my
[ __ ] yeah
yeah [ __ ] the ego man huh
[ __ ] the ego hey listen that's what
everyone says
you're saying in that but it's so it's
it has you it has all of us
oh i know we can't live without it well
it comes
and it's going to come as yeah listen to
something last night on
it was on alan watts under
yeah and he was talking about a buddhist
story or whatever and one a great
buddhist was saying that
that there is no such thing as
permanence
that you will not be a permanently
blissful
yeah or happy yeah just like you won't
be permanently sad
or ego driven that it's going to come
but it's about
let it come and don't run from it yeah
talk about don't be afraid of it take it
yeah and then go through the other side
of that because that's where that's
where the life is
why do we listen to these people the
[ __ ] are these people they don't even
look like us why do we listen to them
from another [ __ ] way of living life
transfer
you know you don't look like and think
like us nothing like why do we listen to
them
why maybe because i'm thinking that it's
an energy that you can feel
wherever you're at at that point if
you're ready for that it'll hit you
just like if you see a pimp on the
corner and that speaks to you and you
say to yourself i want to be like that
that's where you're at
at that time energetically or where you
see a pimp in the corner and you say i'm
not i'm not there
i'm i'm somewhere else i'm not saying
it's better or it's worse but i'm at a
different
energy vibration and frequency
your frequency is your currency oh
that's where you're at
i don't know i think we don't like what
we're doing that's why we listen to
people
you know because that's we we in some
way we take what they say
and we want us to we want the world to
believe that we said it
you know that's the perspective of
ourself
that's the um what i say we do uh what's
that word i used to get
self-reflection or um no [ __ ]
examining yourself yeah inventory
inventory when you do the inventory you
can't live that's why when i do my
inventory i can't lie to myself
yeah you know and i said [ __ ]
you know yeah these are the things that
i have to deal with
yeah it's good that you're a deal you're
asking these but most people are too
afraid to ask questions
well here's the thing though mike about
the ego
and alan watts talks about this is that
the ego is an illusion that you've
created there's no
spot in your brain exactly it generates
this [ __ ]
the ego is this [ __ ] cree this is
creative to protect yourself
to keep yourself safe yes to aspire
because you can't imagine that
you can be the person that everyone
loves and holds up
in all of your successes no my ego tells
me
my eagle knows that i'm a i'm a great
follower of alexander the great my
eagles said [ __ ] that [ __ ]
what it took him 20 years to do you do
one fight
[Laughter]
well it took him 20 years to do for
people to know who he is i do it at one
night
but still i don't want to think of
myself as something great i want you to
do
something has to be great in order for
me to i can't look at me just me i used
to
it's just my low self-esteem maybe it's
says something i have to
want to follow something it's bigger
than me something has to be bigger than
me
yeah i get that what about healthy ego
yeah is there a healthy ego that's what
i think i have i think so no
i think i have a healthy ego yes
because a healthy ego is when you don't
respond to your ego
yeah when you don't act out what it's
telling you to do yes exactly and you
laugh at it no way [ __ ]
you're not going to live in reaction
it's hard to get to that point every
listen
we're human beings and this is the deal
right that no one wants to believe that
sometimes the nicest person in the monks
the [ __ ] sisters to reach the mother
to they think sometimes
they see somebody i want to kick him
with his [ __ ] hair and they know they
can't stop why they think of it i want
to punch him in his [ __ ] face i want
to [ __ ] cast it and we don't know why
we say this think those things
and then we go back that no that's not
good praise be to god oh lord please
forgive me oh jesus please help me and
this and that oh god
and um why do we do that that's why
religion
comes in okay it just gives us a way to
live even though we may think our [ __ ]
religion
this is for the man and this and that
but it gives us a
structure yeah it gives us a spiritual
structure yeah i like that too
because everybody always say hey [ __ ]
religion i'm spiritual but you got
spiritual from religion
you know well no you have to know about
you have to know about religion you have
to hear and hear what these people are
talking about say hey i don't like that
but i like this
this is who i am that's why i see when i
look at books as i said this is who i am
we are who we are and we just we're
seekers like you said
and we don't like certain things about
us and we want to go like this like i
don't like this i like on the raw scene
even though he's a criminal stuff i like
this about him i like the fact that he
likes to teach everybody
like if you want to be in his group if
you want to make money with him
you have to learn how to eat you have to
learn how to [ __ ]
stress yet you know he wanted you to
prepare for life even though he was
criminals he was preparing lucky lucian
all the money
he was he was the father of crime but he
had
class you know he's always dignified
he's
always looking nice he sees somebody
that plays him
get a haircut it was always about
looking good even though
you were doing bad but you were looking
good doing bad
you know it was all about self-image who
he wanted to be like we're discussing
the illusion of ourselves who we are
yeah
you know well
we're running out of time um we can do
it no we got some time we got like 20
minutes
but tony so you're on fox nfl sunday
you're doing that thing you're an
analyst
how has that been when it comes to all
of this stuff
the ego that you had created
this persona that you created as one of
the greatest football players of all
time
transitioning that maybe even killing
that guy
to become this next phase to come into
this next phase of your life
and you've got your podcast wide open
which is dope as hell
and you know you're really a guy that
should be out there speaking
and getting your message and spreading
your light and i'm just curious how has
that been
transitioning into that role from
you know once being at the top of the
mountain in the nfl yeah it was
it was tough at the beginning um i got a
job
from the outside looking in everybody
thought it was like this
cream puff job and i was working for cbs
on the main desk
i was flying out to new york every week
and i loved it while i was there but
just something was stopping me
from being you can never recreate that
football feeling and i've realized it's
not even about it's an emotional thing
but i was and i was i was scared i was
scared to show who i am
in front of the camera when that red
light's on you know there's millions of
people watching
and i was scared and so i had a hard
time with it and i could never
i never felt like i was really myself
and i always apologize to people from
cbs
thank you for my opportunity but it was
like you never really got to see me
in front of that camera uh fooling me
and it's because i was
i was just afraid and i remember i was
um i was up for
renegotiation and i did a good job it
just wasn't
where i wanted it and uh i was in spain
i was sitting in a little cafe i was
with my wife and we were sitting there
talking she's like hey is the deal
almost done and i'm like yeah it's
pretty much done
and she goes like happy with it and i
like like paused
and uh and i started crying and i'm like
she's like what's wrong with you and i
said i
i don't know i i just i feel like i'm
about to have an anxiety attack
like if i signed this contract with them
first of all i was away from my family
because i was i'd have to travel three
days a week and i have those four kids
all in the house and i was like i don't
like being away from them i don't feel
like i am myself on this show for
whatever reason
i just it's just not working for me and
that's kind of when
life took off for me again like from
that moment
that's why rock bottom quote unquote
rock bottom moments are good to me
yeah i like it when i hit that because
that means i'm challenging myself i'm
asking the questions i'm not avoiding
that [ __ ] i'm not going to say i'm going
to do it anyway because i'm afraid
when you're rock bottom there's no
[ __ ] impression yeah
and a lot of people don't want to do
that because they want they'd rather say
oh you know what just keep doing it
you'll get through it it's like no i
need to throw my hands up and say
i don't know i'm stuck right now and i'm
lost but i'm gonna get out of this
and it's gonna work and that's how you
got good people around you my wife is
brilliant brilliant wife or she's like
it is okay it's okay you can do it you
can
and then from that moment i was like i
gotta i can't i can't do this job
anymore
and people were like my agent and my
manager they were both like you're
making a career decision here you're
making a mistake
you'll never get it you're not going to
fox because they don't have any spots
over there
you're not going to esp you're not going
to go do this stuff you're going to have
to freak and i said
i'mma let go i'ma let go and we'll see
it's going to turn out
good for me i'm gonna i can't live like
this i'm not going that way anymore i'm
gonna go the other way and so i dropped
out
started learning uh and obviously and
it's funny how life opens up
that's why i always say one of my quotes
is life takes off on the other side of
fear
once you look at that tony once you can
go through it
it's funny how the universe or life
whatever you believe in opens up to you
and says
yeah there you go son daughter yeah you
did it
now i'm gonna reward you for that yeah
because you were afraid to do that most
people are afraid
and that's what i'm saying that's where
you want to be in life and that's why
you want to be in uncomfortable
situations
you want to be in front of the cam this
microphone to just to
expand yourself you know to get better
and that's what took off for me and then
i was able to it's funny fox opened up
real
into the stories a job opened up at fox
miraculously the guy who was there
to go to the fbi peanut tillman oh no he
went to the fbi
and his spot opened up and they're like
wow and it's funny it's like wow
open course and then the things that
happened to me at fox i love working
there so much the
the atmosphere is so great the guys like
michael strahan and terry bradshaw and
howie long and
michael vick i'm working with charissa
thompson like it goes on and on like i
love the execs it's it's my vibe
it's it's me and it's 10 minutes from
the house
go ahead i guess um this is what my
mentor taught me
you know after him living his life he's
born in 1908 but after him living all
this crazy life and doing it
this is what he told me when you have
everything in the world
when you have it all you know
there has to be something worth giving
it up for
not your family it is it has to be
something in you
this has to be worth something after you
have to give
it give it up [ __ ] lose it all you know
like when i was hearing you saying all
this good thing oh we gotta do this
we're gonna get this and then some
people in their school
how do we rebuild yeah how do you how do
you
reset your mind and say hey [ __ ] that
[ __ ] [ __ ] we gonna do it again yeah
but it's hard though it was hard it's
not like it didn't
yeah i made that decision it's not like
it got immediately better like
i still was in some [ __ ] for once
without struggle there's no progress
who we are yes yeah you know and that's
the worst that's what we don't want to
find out
life prepares us it forces us to find
out who we are
yeah yeah you know and like who we are
because we're not going to like who we
are sometimes and we have the life has
forced us to like who we are and accept
who we are
whatever happened to me yeah and accept
who we are
it's like being in the mirror so i did a
lot of techniques too
like uh there's this great lady who i've
had on wide open too it's an
unbelievable
obsession with her name's marissa pearce
she's a hypnotherapist
i grew up him since i was 14 i've been
getting hypnotized you know my whole
career i don't do it anymore but i just
know the kind i do it to myself
yeah well i said i don't do it no more
so i yeah i do it to myself
so i wrote one of her big things was i
am enough
uh it's such a big one i wrote that in
my wife's lipstick
and it stayed up in that same lipstick i
told the the
the people when they come you know
helped us clean the house that don't
take that down
and i stayed there for a year so every
day i'd look into the mirror i would see
i am enough
like i got this that's definitely you
have to it's just like on
on the football field that that's kind
of the probably the biggest thing that
was stopping me while i was dropping the
balls when that ball was coming to me it
was don't drop the ball
don't drop it and i'd catch it most of
the time but i would drop it
occasionally and that's why i led the
league and dropped passes where i had to
switch that mentality
along with falling in love with it and
getting catches before practice
an extra 300 catches a day versus what i
was doing before
uh it was it was i got this when that
ball's in there
it's like there's nothing you can do how
much do your wife
and family have to do that right that
much how much do they have to do with
that
the energy you just had you see all that
stuff how much do your wife
i wanted to talk about your wife how
much your wife have to do with that
she's
she's everything to me she's she's you
talk about
my ego she she is the one who can build
me up
but not tear me down she's always like
you got this before shows big like we
left for the super bowl week she's like
you're going to do a great job this week
and it's part of that alexander the
great or cus with you
like telling somebody that you love and
respect that will tell you that you can
do this and that you it's like being a
great parent
it's like tell your kids that there's
you are limitless
yeah and you are powerful if you keep
your ego in check and you go this way
you're gonna it's not if it's when it's
going to come to you
and so i believe that if you
if you have if you can walk around with
that feeling when the [ __ ] comes with
the inevitable [ __ ] that's going to come
it's going to happen to you but you just
know it's like kind of like trust
it's like when you stepped into the ring
or when i stepped on the field
and you stepped on the field you have to
really trust that's confidence yeah like
trust it's going to work yeah it's going
to and if i get if you get one
you beat me on this play i'm gonna come
back uh
and i'm prepared to go to the distance
and a lot of that
being prepared comes from
i don't know maybe how you grew up that
that dog mentality
we talk about that no listen um on on in
a sport athletic field
this is what um
mama ali amazes me in so many different
fashions because when i look at mama i
think
from one i don't think mom and dad have
had a street fight he had um
it was a big guy it was a guy that was a
bouncer
and everybody was afraid of him and then
they put in st louis
and louisville right and um he was a
boxer too
so he was a tough guy and everybody he
beat up like knocks guys out in the bar
you know because he's the bouncer and
stuff and so i
gene taylor was ali's was boxing while
he was scared to definitely but he just
was hitting him with the jab he broke
his nose and they stopped the fight or
something
and i believe king killer told me ali
stayed in the house until he was scared
the guy was going to beat him up and
stuff
you know but just to see a guy like that
listen
he was that he was using this thing
talking [ __ ] about sonny liston
and your ugly bear and something
and i was saying listen smacked him
right
and ali was scared he didn't know what
to do right so how do you come from
being afraid of this guy to the next
thing you know you're kicking his ass
and
what does that confidence come from
where did they come where did it come
from him getting smacked
to like i'ma kick his [ __ ] ass what
happened here's my opinion because i had
a bully when i was growing up
and he used to come every single day and
i would strategically hide my skateboard
i lived at huntington beach so we did
that
and i would skate home and i was
definitely scared of this guy
i didn't go to school dances i didn't
hang out after school i heard the
stories how this guy beat two guys up
and smashed one in the head with a brick
and i was just
and uh it culminated at the end of my
school year
we everybody graduated i went and hit at
my eighth grade graduation my whole
family's looking for me
and it was like out of a movie they all
came up and they saw me
and i was cowering behind a wall and i
remember
that was the remember i played pop
warner football before that and i said
to myself i'll never
see that look on their face again my
mom's facing my brother's face
my brother chris everybody else i can't
remember but i remember seeing my mom's
face she just she didn't say a word
she just looked at me and gave me that
look like like just absolute
disappointment
and my brother now the words he was like
what are you doing because they had all
known about they had been trying to get
me to fight this guy but i was scared
and i remember i said to myself ever
again
i will take a ass whooping i don't care
i will die before i run away from
anybody ever again
and i think that's part of it i've been
noticing this too about these movers and
shakers
we're very sensitive people yeah and
that embarrassment and the same thing
when i dropped all those balls i was
like that will
never happen again i won't be that guy
dropping balls
yeah i'm i'd rather i will i will kill
myself be
like not kill kill myself literally i
will
i will go to the ends of the earth and
i'll do whatever it takes i'll run
a hundred sprints after practice i will
jeopardize my body now
like you said i will beat it up to
oblivion in order to not go through that
feeling again i don't ever want that
feeling again
and i you have to you have to get past
that though you have to get past that
yeah um i'm a big believer but that
guided me through that time in my life
it's dope man mike yeah
we gotta wrap it up we gotta wrap it
tony man thank you
so much brother yeah and really hey
check out
you want to give a shout out for your
social media stuff uh
yeah tony gonzalez88 you can check me
out there or you can go to the wide open
all major podcast platforms and
and check that out awesome you got
anything with fox until next football
season
nothing you guys are good yeah guys
before we go
yeah right me you all three of us right
what the [ __ ] why do we think that
[ __ ] gotta watch us and we
gotta look at [ __ ]
why do we think that all right we know
listen
why do we why are we born thinking that
you know that's the most
we want people to watch us excite you
know we want to entertain people want
people to [ __ ] suck our things we
want people to worship but that's the
word
that way well i think for the podcast no
listen listen why we want people to
worship us why we why we think we're
that person why do we think we're
descendants from god
they know individually we don't think
that we think we're better than people
in a certain way
we don't say but in a way we can look
why is everybody like that and we're
like this
well my my thing on that is it just that
we don't they don't want to put in the
work no it's more than that
i felt that way at the beginning and i
think a lot i felt that way
uh and i don't think he's wrong with
that i was just part of my growth
process but at this point now
i think the reason you're sitting here
and you're sitting here is because
we feel like we have a story to tell
that can help people it's coming from a
place of love now
to like yeah don't like i don't i don't
believe in uh
the chosen one like we were talking
backstage before we came on
like the movie the matrix i love that
movie yeah because he finally figures
out that he is the one and i believe
everybody if you're the one then i'm the
one and you're the one anybody out there
listening
like you have an amazing power to go out
there and do all this there's
there the success leaves clues yeah
listen to these stories
and to and uh try them out don't be
afraid and that that's part of it at
least that's
at least i like to think and maybe
there's a little ego in that too
yeah ego is know what else we go with
ego is believing that we've gone into an
afterlife and we're not gonna die our
ego think we're gonna live forever
that's you know when the reality is
[ __ ] like everything else
we're gone it's the experience of life
and we should appreciate that
but we want to live forever isn't that
interesting
it is well you guys will get into it
more all right
hey everybody hey thanks for listening
to this episode of hotbox and thank you
tony for coming
it's great to have you in here man
sharing your wisdom we've had a personal
opinion about him that's totally wrong
and [ __ ]
yeah i know the guy's [ __ ] cool man
hey everybody
life is great life is great thanks for
watching this episode of hot boxing
check out tony's pod wide open
i'm gonna be on there next until next
time i'm evan britton and i'm mike tyson
and we're ready hey do you want anybody
to know anything about you or anything
thank you
they said wikipedia come on now
[Music]
[Music]
two